[Music]
[Applause]
he is the athletic director at Notre
Dame he is Jack swarbrick and uh set to
leave that position but certainly left
his mark on college football can't tell
the story of college football the good
stuff without Jack swarbrick the Notre
Dame athletic director kind enough to
join us here on The Dan Patrick Show Oh
flying the Notre Dame colors there
Jack's saying hello to USC Alum Will
Ferrell
uh Jack thanks for joining us uh you see
how happy I am that Father John is not
representing
on this show wow yeah
um yeah did you did you take in all of
that I did
okay I thought the obvious question
wasn't asked and that was who was the
model
who's you know what we I we don't know
that's a great question not me no
we'll get some of our best people on it
uh how did this concept come up with
Notre Dame playing in uh in Dublin I
know that it's happened before but how
did it come up well we uh we try very
hard to get around the world and the
country with these games
um this happens to be part of the
aerolingus series and so it's not
technically a Shamrock Series game but
on average every other year we'll be in
Lambeau against Wisconsin coming up we
played in Fenway Park Yankee Stadium we
were in Las Vegas last year and this is
our third time in Ireland what kind of
hurdles do you go through trying to get
something like this done where it's out
of the country it's it's pretty
interesting uh and I'm sure the NFL
has become much more of an expert than
we are at this but it's it's a lot of
simple things like the drugs that your
team doctor
normally has it a game right you're now
you're bringing into a different country
yeah and you've got to have somebody in
that country who can help you uh
prescribe those drugs if they're needed
um players I've got a guy
if you're having any issues player
passports you know how many
you know because not everybody has a
passport when they're 18 or 19 years of
age yeah that's right and uh usually
about we'll find out about a quarter to
a third of our team doesn't have a
passport and so you're engaged in that
whole process also when we landed our
cab drivers were talking about Gaelic
football and that Gaelic football is
real football and maybe that was the uh
precursor to NFL football or college
football but they were talking about how
violent it is where you guys get to wear
pads and uh they don't so Gaelic foot
did Gaelic football precede college
football
um I assume it did I was watching a
little of it this afternoon as a matter
of fact yeah it's uh it's a really
interesting game I know nothing about it
well I I was rugby I I said what's the
difference between Gaelic football and
rugby and then my cab driver goes that's
a good question but you didn't know so
the scrum is missing I can tell you that
yeah there's the there's not that uh how
would you compare if we're looking at
the Cowboys fan base is that similar
Duke basketball Notre Dame football is
there comparisons that you have with
other sports you know I think what
distinguishes us the most is the number
of people
who for a host of reasons some
historical some faith-based
um supporters that have never been to
South Bend never been to a Notre Dame
game you know we were in San Diego
several years ago sold the place outs
and you know those were a lot of people
who
were Subway alums in the sense that
they've just adopted Notre Dame so I
think that's one of the big differences
uh can you sum up what's happened with
college football in the last where would
you start complete disaster
how did it how did we get here Jack I
wish I knew and and listen I'm not uh
everybody in the industry has to take
responsibility here I'm not uh excluding
myself from that I think uh the
decision-making
lost its way in terms of the focus on
the student athlete and what's primarily
best for them
um but we are where we are and we have
to try and make it work I mean we've
been pretty
uh vocal in the past month about we need
to find a home for Stanford and Cal that
you can't have two of the great academic
institutions in the world not have a not
have a place to play
what kind of solution you got
we're working on it meaning well there's
still consideration of the ACC as a home
for those schools okay and Notre Dame is
lobbying for Stanford and cow to join
very much so okay and the Pac-12 dies
it's looking that way more and more
every day yes
but it can I go back and say this chain
if we didn't do this or we did do this
that would have changed everything or
kept it I mean uh Chip Kelly has talked
about why don't we just have you know
the football schools play the football
schools and then the other uh athletic
programs don't have to travel to
Piscataway or you know Syracuse or those
kind of things I mean that that seems
like obvious that you could be able to
still do that and not have the baseball
team travel uh you know all across the
country I'm all for more Regional
scheduling yeah I think I think it makes
a load of sense it doesn't mean you need
to separate out football operationally
right I think I think we can all still
stay under the same umbrella
um but I'd like to see much more
Regional scheduling could you see where
we're headed towards the NFL model
with college football let's say you have
50 teams uh split it up with uh
divisions
yeah a little hard to get there because
of
the conflicting media rights deals and
assignment of Rights and so those things
don't ever line up on the calendar basis
so a little hard to see how you get
there but it's likely within the next
year uh
either in an action involving USC or a
federal case in Pennsylvania uh student
athletes football and basketball players
will be declared employees you think
that's where we should be headed I don't
it's it's not about not supporting them
and making sure there are ample benefits
available
um we were the first school in the
country to advocate for name image and
likeness uh back in back in 2015. but I
don't think they need to be employees we
still want them to be part of the
student body and and involved in a lot
of the same experiences as the normal
student has but is this based on Greed
or how much is with with what's going on
with and the people in power who are
making these you know the kids are going
to be the kids but you got grown-ups who
have made decisions that seem like
they're just based on money yeah well
they're certainly based on money there's
there's no question and uh some of that
is the demands that have Arisen over
time for to find more Revenue
to meet this requirement or this
requirement so I'm not terribly
comfortable with the description of his
greed but it is all about money
he's the athletic director at Notre Dame
Jack sportbrick uh do you have a
question for will
Jack will how do you feel about your new
ad
um
Washington former Washington A.D right
yeah okay good pull
I'm excited I think it's a you know it's
it's
great to have a female ad at USC uh she
obviously uh I mean I can't say that
I've studied athletic directors uh but
it feels like it's a strong move right
let me I got a question for you jack
your replacement is Pete bavaqua that's
right any relation to Kurt Bev aqua
I don't believe so okay
oh they're not related I thought that
they were somehow they saw that name and
thought I didn't yeah right Pete has
never shared that with me if they are
could we Google that and see I thought I
thought the uh athletic director the new
one is is related to him
was he a padre Kurt Bevan he was yeah
yeah yeah all right maybe we learned
something together here Jack
perhaps yeah
um when when you look at these service
academies
um are they going to be able to stay
competitive with the uh other division
one programs moving down the road
I sure hope so and I think they've got a
lot of things going for them
um
there have been some rule changes in
recent years designed to ensure player
safety that's made it a little harder to
be a triple option team
um but they've certainly had some some
recent years of great success between
Army and Navy so that's our hope
uh what would you have to hear to join a
conference
um
that we didn't have a media partner
uh that we didn't have a fair path to
the college football playoff if the NBC
media plan was not there
would Notre Dame be in a conference yeah
if we didn't have somebody else who's
willing to step up yes okay and would
that be the Big Ten
I don't know
I'd uh it'd be interesting to have that
discussion with with each of the
available conferences you haven't had
those discussions before we've had lots
of uh inquiries we've never negotiated
or participated how does that work when
there's inquiries what happens
um usually it's a president-to-president
call
uh where someone from a conference a
president from a conference is assigned
a call in this case father Jenkins and
say
maybe are you considering a different
path and we say no
and then it gets down to you are you
involved in the the process after that
yeah with the phone call what's the
closest Notre Dame's ever come to
joining a conference
[Music]
be close but if we hadn't been able to
find a home for our Olympic sports with
the ACC
maintaining football Independence would
have been problematic we needed a
partner who would
who would allow our Olympic sports to
participate at the level we want them to
and it I I guess it's not as lucrative
having your own you know TV network but
joining the ACC you're there with other
sports uh you do play some ACC schools
but is that a possibility down the road
well
all the major conferences are a
possibility okay um we play hockey in
the Big Ten we have the other Olympic
sports in the ACC and football's
independent
what are you going to do when you step
down
I don't know I get a great piece of
advice that said don't agree to do
anything for six months
so I'm gonna I'm gonna try and follow
that but yeah I'm I'm eager to stay
involved in the in the industry
well thanks for joining us and uh thanks
for the contributions to college
football uh college football will not be
better off without you that's for sure
hopefully you stay in the mix there can
you run the NCAA Jack actually I think
they have a great guy right now Charlie
Baker okay I'm not sure you can govern
that thing but if it's governable he's
the he's the right person to try are we
going to do away with the NCAA
should we
you you you you can't have an
association
of 3 000 anything
right there's just not enough
commonality of Interest yeah so do we
need it
we need we we need some governing
entities as you point out it could be
one someday which is the 50
most well-known Brands yeah
um but it's tough to govern across so
many different models of College
athletics it's just hard
great to see you have fun over the
weekend and thanks for joining us my
pleasure thank you very much Jack
swarbrick the university vice president
and the uh director of Athletics we'll
come back uh last call for phone calls
what we learned what's in store tomorrow
right after this